merci d'être avec nous pour cette
demi-heure Olivier Hainaut vous êtes
sénateur centriste du Nord
vice-président de la commission des
affaires sociales rapporteur de ce
budget de la Sécurité sociale dont on va
longuement parler dans quelques instants
mais d'abord l'actualité du côté du nord
du côté de Lille elle a été tragique ce
weekend avec l'effondrement de deux
immeubles en plein centre-ville de Lille
c'était samedi matin une victime est-ce
que vous avez des informations un peu
plus précises sur les circonstances de
ces effondrements et sur la situation
actuelle sur place
je me suis rendu sur sur place j'ai
évidemment une pensée pour la famille du
médecin psychiatre décédé
accidentellement il devait pas être là
d'ailleurs mais on lui avait prêté cet
appartement c'est tragique puis même
l'avait été dans la nuit même l'action
des étudiants qui sont des héros parce
que ils ont fait su faire preuve à la
fois de pertinence et puis aussi de
solidarité puisqu'ils se sont soucier de
toutes les personnes qui vivaient dans
l'immeuble bon maintenant on est au cœur
du vieux Lille ce ne sont pas des
immeubles insalubre mais comme toutes
ces villes anciennes elles ont
quelquefois été construites sous avec
des fondations peut-être plus incertaine
voilà maintenant je crois que tous ces
immeubles doivent être contrôlés le plus
en plus souvent notamment avec quelques
fois une sécheresse plus plus marquée
qui peut changer l'équilibre des donc il
faut être extrêmement vigilant sur tout
ce qui concerne ces immeubles du vieux
Lille
l'actualité c'est la politique migrat
oire
du Pas-de-Calais 142 migrants qui ont
été sauvés selon la préfecture maritime
plus selon la mère de Calais Natacha
Bouchard il tentait de rejoindre le
Royaume-Uni ils sont à Dunkerque c'est
ce qu'a dit hier Olivier Véran est-ce
qu'il faut que la France et le
Royaume-Uni prennent de nouvelles
mesures comment on évite ces traversées
dangereuses alors je crois que c'est un
grand sujet et on n'a pas fini d'en
parler sur ces questions il faut faire
preuve d'humanité parce qu'on peut pas
laisser les personnes se noyer dans la
Manche ou dans la Méditerranée mais en
même temps la fermeté voyez je suis
d'une génération qui ne pensait pas être
confrontée à des questions aussi lourdes
aussi graves il faut qu'on passe le
message à la jeunesse de l'Afrique
subsaharienne qu'elle n'est pas bien
venue en Europe et que ils doivent
rester chez eux pour être plus heureux
c'est chez eux c'est au Mali au Niger
qui sont en capacité de construire leur
bonheur et pas en étant imm clandestin
chez nous je crois que c'est très
important donc humanité par rapport à
ceux qui sont là intégration aussi mais
passer ce message parce que un jeune
africain me disait que il y avait
environ la moitié de la jeunesse de
l'Afrique subsaharienne qui souhaitait
venir en Europe c'est pas possible ça on
peut pas y arriver
arriver de passeur qui mentent
les filières de pasteur mentent mais il
faut aussi que alors il y a les deux
développements mais il faut que
l'Afrique soit en capacité d'organiser
son développement ce qui avait fait
Jean-Louis Borloo sur l'Afrique et sur
sur l'électrification de l'Afrique et et
très pertinent il faut que cette
jeunesse construit arrive à construire
son bonheur et et son avenir en Afrique
et que et qui puisse comprendre que
c'est pas en venant en Europe de manière
clandestine en prenant des risques en
prenant le risque de se noyer en
Méditerranée ou dans la Manche on voit
là il faut qu'on arrête ça parce que on
peut pas être submergé c'est nos valeurs
aussi qui sont en jeu c'est à dire nos
valeurs ça veut dire qu'il y a un risque
en cas de trop forte immigration ben moi
je voudrais pas que face à
comment dire d'une immigration
clandestine massive et bien finalement
ce soit les populismes les extrémismes
qui l'emportent et qu'on
doivent revenir ou qu'on revienne sur
nos principes humanistes et et sur les
valeurs de notre démocratie qui nous
seront chères parce que serait le serait
la négation de nous-mêmes mais sur le
Chen Vikings est-ce que la France a eu
raison de le laisser accoster à Toulon
ou est-ce qu'elle a plié face à l'Italie
oh écoutez je pense qu'on peut pas
laisser les gens se noyer dans la mer
quand même je vais vous dire là on parle
quand même que de 200 personnes mais la
question elle est pas là on peut pas
avoir dans nos centres-villes dans nos
villes des personnes qui sont en
situation irrégulière dont on sait pas
de quoi elles vivent qui n'ont pas de
papier et on peut pas non plus accepter
une immigration massive non contrôlée et
aujourd'hui la France les capacités
d'intégration c'est ce que vous nous
dites en tous les cas pas aussi
massivement c'est pas c'est pas possible
ce dont on parle vous voyez quand on
parle de la jeunesse africaine
subsaharienne là aussi les invités à
avoir un contrôle des naissances on peut
pas continuer et puis ils peuvent pas
continuer à voir 5 6 7 enfants par femme
vous voyez je suis rapporteur de la
branche famille
au Sénat sur le père FSS la natalité
c'est un sujet mais il faut qu'elle soit
contrôlée voilà tout ça doit être fait
vous imposer des politiques natalistes
au pays africain
vous savez bien que c'est pas mais on
les invite à le faire si il faut aussi
faire ça en responsabilité je pense
qu'on a un rôle par rapport à l'Afrique
c'est on est proche on est cousin même
et il faut avoir ce dialogue de
responsabilité le développement de
l'Afrique c'est ça la clé et faire en
sorte que la jeunesse africaine
construit son bonheur et sa vie en
Afrique et que il renonce au mirage de
l'Europe et de la France on parlait de
l'actualité au Sénat du budget de la
Sécurité sociale puisque vous avez
examiné ce budget ce week-end on voit
tout ça avec Alex pusard
[Musique]
bonjour Oriane bonjour Olivier Hainaut
bonjour et Alex samedi il y avait séance
et la majorité de droite et du centre du
Sénat à adopter sa propre réforme des
retraites durant l'examen du budget de
la Sécu mais oui comme tous les ans la
droite sénatoriale propose sa réforme
des retraites via un amendement au
budget de la Sécurité sociale et cette
année cet amendement prévoyait d'abord
une concertation d'un an entre les
différents partenaires sociaux pour
trouver une solution pour équilibrer
notre système de retraite et en cas
d'échec des négociations des mesures
seraient prises les voici d'abord un
recul de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans une augmentation de la
durée de cotisation pour atteindre 43
annuités dès le départ en retraite de la
génération 1967 et puis la convergence
des différents régimes spéciaux de
retraite avant 2023 des mesures qui
finalement ressemblent à la réforme
souhaitée par Emmanuel Macron mais le
gouvernement un calendrier à différents
il souhaite d'abord consulter les
partenaires sociaux avant de présenter
son texte écouter le ministre en charge
des solidarités
nous avons fait le choix de la
concertation et d'un projet de loi en
janvier pas d'une mesure dans un projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour cette raison le
gouvernement demande le retrait de cette
amendement voilà défavorable du
gouvernement mais pour la majorité de
droits de sénatoriales c'est amendement
est quand même
utile ne serait-ce que pour ouvrir le
débat avec les avec l'exécutif sur la
réforme des retraites
vous connaissez notre position
aujourd'hui et à partir de notre
position nous sommes prêts à discuter
mais nous avions besoin de ce message
politique pour dire clairement où nous
voulons aller et pourquoi nous voulons
le faire au moins nous avons le mérite
ici au Sénat d'être cohérent dans notre
démarche d'avoir des solutions à
apporter qu'elles plaisent au Quai des
plaises mais en tous les cas d'avoir une
vraie responsabilité sur cet enjeu
fondamental pour maintenir à la fois
notre système de retraite les niveaux de
pension et surtout corriger des
inégalités alors dans le débat samedi il
y avait un côté de l'hémicycle qui a été
opposé sur le fond à cette réforme des
retraites il s'agit de la gauche du
Sénat les sénateurs écologistes
socialistes et communiste estime que
cette réforme serait injuste socialement
qu'elle n'est pas forcément si urgente
au niveau financier quand on regarde de
près les prévisions du corps le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites et puis il y
a d'autres solutions qui existent
écoutez la sénatrice communiste Laurence
Cohen pour résoudre le déficit qui est
prévu par le corps en 2027 il suffirait
d'augmenter de 4 euros 50 le salaire
mensuel à partir de 2023 et mon
envisageant de ne pas accabler les
patrons de couper la poire en deux et de
l'augmenter de 2,50 € en plus pour les
cotisations employeurs et 2 euros pour
les cotisations salariées vous avez
résolu le problème du déficit du système
de retraite en tout cas au terme de ce
débat les groupes les républicains et
centrices du Sénat ont voté à la
majorité en faveur de cette amendement
sans se faire trop d'illusions sur son
sort notamment à l'Assemblée nationale
avec un une possibilité du 49-3 par le
gouvernement Olivier Hainaut d'abord un
mot sur la méthode est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment réformer les retraites via un
amendement au budget de la Sécurité
sociale ou est-ce que c'était un message
politique envoyé au gouvernement vous
savez en matière de de réforme de
retraite c'est toujours trop tôt trop
tard il y a question de forme il y a les
Yaka faucon bon nous on a voulu marquer
l'importance de de cette réforme et de
d'une réforme qui est mesurée
[Musique]
c'est vrai encore avec le chèque essence
là c'est vrai quand toutes les boucliers
de ceci les boucliers de cela et donc on
est dans un système extrêmement
redistributif et donc on a plus d'argent
pour investir dans les services publics
et pour faire fonctionner correctement
nos services publics c'est ça le drame
du pays
qu'on consacre une bonne partie de
l'argent prélevé par les impôts ou par
les cotisations sociales au
fonctionnement des services publics à
l'investissement dans ces services
publics ça craque de partout mais sur
les secrets
pour la part des retraites
on dépense 14 % de notre richesse pour
le pour les retraites on peut pas
dépenser plus c'est pas possible parce
que sans ça ça va craquer de partout
c'est ça la responsabilité et c'est ça
que la majorité du Sénat et nous le
groupe usé et je vais vous dire
Sénat d'avoir ce message de
responsabilité et à l'intérieur le
groupe centriste c'est l'heure du Sénat
d'ailleurs en quelque sorte ce qui se
passe c'est à dire que on peut pas se
balader sans que les gens nous disent ah
bah ça se passe mieux au Sénat à
l'Assemblée bah oui et ben c'est c'est
la démonstration de l'utilité du
bicamérisme d'ailleurs et donc ce recul
de l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à
64 ans pour vous ça doit être un totem
il y a pas d'autre solution
mais on vit de plus en plus longtemps en
bonne forme on est en capacité de
travailler la question elle est elle est
pas tellement quand vous parlez aux gens
la question n'est pas tellement de de
travailler plus longtemps ça les
angoisse pas tant que ça ce qui les
angoisse c'est de pouvoir arriver jusque
là et donc c'est l'emploi du seniors ce
qui les angoisse c'est d'être bien payés
jusque là et d'avoir des salaires qui
soient dignes c'est ça la question qui
est la nôtre mais maintenant faire en
sorte de maîtriser nos prélèvements
c'est ça la responsabilité pour pouvoir
investir et faire fonctionner
correctement nos services publics de
santé d'éducation les routes enfin tout
ce qui est l'environnement aussi tout ce
qui concerne l'organisation du pays et
justement avec son emploi des seniors
sur l'emploi des seniors si justement on
travaille plus longtemps est-ce que ça
ne va pas augmenter le chômage des
seigneurs qui est déjà très élevé et au
final coûtait plus cher au système
non si on crée un indice senior c'est à
dire non seulement une incitation que
les entreprises gardent les seniors plus
longtemps ils peuvent être utiles ils
sont utiles notamment en matière
d'apprentissage et et faire en sorte là
aussi on crée des bonus malus un peu
partout et bien avoir aussi sur l'emploi
du Seigneur pour les entreprises une
forme de bonus malus sur les cotisations
patronales et comme ça on va résoudre ce
problème Alex sur le reste parce que
c'est là où ça le bilan de ce budget de
la Sécurité sociale qu'est-ce qu'on peut
retenir des modifications apportées par
le Sénat durant l'examen alors c'est
assez rare pour être souligné mais la
majorité de droite du Sénat a voté des
surtaxes de nouveaux prélèvements des
efforts en tout cas exceptionnels pour
certains organismes de santé qui ont
fait des bénéfices notamment pendant la
période covid avec d'abord une surtaxe
de 300 millions d'euros sur les
mutuelles les sénateurs estiment que les
mutuelles ne participent pas assez au
financement de notre système de santé et
puis un autre effort exceptionnel
demandé au laboratoire d'analyses de un
effort de 250 millions d'euros en 2023
mais les sénateurs s'opposent à la
baisse de tarifs des laboratoires qui
est demandé par le gouvernement c'est
laboratoire qui ont notamment fait des
bénéfices avec tous les tests covid
remboursés par la Sécurité Sociale et
puis une autre surtaxe voter par le
Sénat elle concerne le tabac avec une
hausse de la fiscalité sur le tabac à
chauffer c'est à dire du tabac qu'on
chauffe qu'on ne brûle pas contrairement
au tabac classique et puis également une
surtaxe pour doubler le prix des puffs
ce sont ces cigarettes électroniques
jetables qui ont différents goûts et qui
ont beaucoup de succès notamment chez
nos jeunes et le risque c'est que ça
soit une porte d'entrée vers la
cigarette et puis enfin on peut noter
que la majorité du Sénat a souhaité
encadrer davantage le développement de
la télémédecine pas de cabine de
télémédecine dans les supermarchés des
prisescriptions d'arrêt de travail en
télémédecine mais limité et un
renouvellement d'arrêt de travail se
fera obligatoirement via une
consultation physique Olivier Hainaut un
mot sur les laboratoires d'analyses
médicales qui sont en grève cette
semaine contre la réforme du
gouvernement qui souhaite baisser leur
tarifs la majorité du Sénat leur demande
une surtaxe un effort exceptionnel de
250 millions d'euros qu'est-ce que vous
dites à ces laboratoire en Grèce qui est
bien refusent ces efforts exceptionnels
les chiffres parlent le chiffre
d'affaires de ces laboratoires a été
doublé et la marge elle est passée de
15% à 30% bon quel est le secteur
d'activité qui
bénéficie de d'un tel effet d'aubaine il
y a eu un effet d'aubaine et donc ils
doivent contribuer à la solidarité c'est
pas bien compliqué on peut pas accepter
que d'ailleurs c'est sur argent public
enfin argent commun celui de la sécurité
sociale ou des mutuelles et donc il est
normal de de demander à ses laboratoires
de participer à la solidarité nationale
voilà c'est tout simple c'est la réalité
d'énergie demander une taxe c'est pas
une baisse plus pérenne comme comme le
faire le gouvernement bah parce que la
taxe c'est le s’exerce tout de suite et
donc c'est par rapport d'ailleurs au
passé il est pas sûr non plus que le
chiffre d'affaires reste aussi élevé et
donc on consacre on constate vous dites
il y a eu un effet d'aubaine et c'est un
effet d'aubaine il est pas juste et donc
il faut qu'il contribue à la solidarité
nationale c'est tout simple le Sénat qui
je le disais va doubler le prix des
puffs c'est petites cigarettes
électroniques jetables très en vogue
notamment au lycée au collège c'est un
vrai risque pour les jeunes aujourd'hui
c'est pas c'est la porte d'entrée du du
du tabac ou de la cigarette or la
question n'est pas la taxe la question
c'est c'est la santé publique c'est et
toute façon même les taxes ne couvrent
pas le drame de de ce qui se passe quand
les gens fument en termes de cancer
voilà donc on a constaté que c'était la
porte d'entrée et que c'était pas un
substitut et donc il est juste de le
taxer d'autant plus qu'on a constaté
aussi que c'était des très jeunes ou des
des jeunes adolescents sont souvent
mineurs qui
et bien utilisé ce type de produit moi
j'avoue que je les connais pas bien ces
types de produits mais ça se développe
très fortement il fallait prendre une
décision pour pas que là aussi on ait
une surconsommation dans ce domaine qui
prépare des générations tabac demain et
puis on finit par un mot sur la
télémédecine pourquoi encadrer aussi
fortement son développement qui
peut-être même à freiner le
développement de la télémédecine alors
la télémédecine elle peut se justifier
parce qu'on a un problème de pénurie là
aussi de médecin moi ça me met en colère
d'ailleurs que notre pays voyez on a on
a je m'arrête juste là-dessus mais on a
supprimé le le
numéro slausus bon on ne forme que 13
mètres 13% de médecins en plus c'est pas
possible que dans un grand pays comme ça
et je trouve que je suis en colère moi
contre la techno structure le Conseil de
l'Ordre les doyens des facultés il faut
augmenter le nombre de médecins
conformes autrement on a des élèves
brillants qui sont rejetés et qui vont
se former en Roumanie mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ça bon sang qu'on double notre
nombre de médecins formés et donc la
télémédecine oui parfois mais ça peut
pas être
généralisé partout je voulais juste dire
aussi qu'on a pris une mesure très
importante au Sénat c'est par rapport à
l'agir Carco
on ne veut pas transférer les
cotisations le prélèvement des
cotisations à l'URSSAF parce que l'agir
karko ça fonctionne bien c'est le
paritarisme nous on est attaché au
paritarisme et autre mesure très
importante on a fait en sorte aussi de
préserver les finances des départements
s'il y a des évolutions de dépenses
sociales par rapport aux soins
infirmiers ou aux soins à domicile et
bien c'est à l'État à supporter ces
charges et pas au département donc on a
été très ambitieux au Sénat sur le PLFSS
sur le bilan puisque vous faites le
bilan il y a eu un examen un peu tronqué
à l'Assemblée nationale à cause du 49-3
quel bilan vous faites de cet examen au
Sénat avec le gouvernement comment ça
s'est passé
alors du point de vue du dialogue avec
les ministres sur la forme bien
évidemment des textes sont arrivés au
dernier moment mais je vais vous dire
il y a besoin d'une grande loi santé
quand je disais tout à l'heure que ça
craque de partout ça craque à l'hôpital
il y a le problème de la médecine de
ville on a la pénurie de médecin on peut
pas continuer comme ça et donc un PLFSS
c'est une c'est le financement de la
santé de la famille de la retraite de
nos systèmes sociaux mais c'est pas une
loi santé donc on passe des amendements
ici des amendements
il est temps de parce que moi je ne
rentre pas dans la dialectique des
moyens seulement bien évidemment faut
consacrer de l'argent au service public
et à l'investissement et au
fonctionnement des services publics mais
la question n'est pas seulement dans la
diatti des moyens elle est dans notre
capacité de s'organiser on a un déficit
d'organisation et trop de
technostructures voilà il faut que la
haute administration elle laisse les
soignants gérer la santé il faut revoir
ça il y a l'hôpital de Valenciennes par
exemple qui fonctionne remarquablement
le ils ont diminué les coûts
d'administration à 5 % aujourd'hui dans
certains hôpitaux on a 20 % de coût
d'administration il faut qu'on arrive à
mieux s'organiser pour plus dépenser en
faveur de la santé sur le terrain merci
Alex à tout à l'heure on va parler d'un
tout autre sujet on parlera du secours
des migrants en mer et ce sera dans le
club dans une demi-heure on va voir
l'actualité dans nos régions maintenant
Olivier Hainaut pour terminer on va
Strasbourg on retrouve Olivier Claudon
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Olivier journaliste politique aux
Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace et avec
vous on va parler des zones à faible
émission les choses se précisent du côté
de chez vous
[Musique]
les deux exécutifs se sont rencontrés ce
printemps et
le du côté de news on prépare un atelier
de projet pour justement préparer
l'instauration de la zdfe l'atelier de
projet sera mis en place d'ici les
prochaines semaines sachant que Mulhouse
va s'inspirer ou pas de la méthode
strasbourgeoise puisque la ZF 13
bourgeoise a été négocié un peu dans la
douleur parce que la ZFE fait peur aux
automobilistes et aux élus et cette
semaine l'exécutif Strasbourg a présenté
deux éléments particulièrement
intéressants le premier c'est qu'il
assoupi les règles de mise en oeuvre de
la zone affaiblissement au 1er janvier
en tout cas il augmente le nombre de
dérogations
à ces règles de d'interdiction
circulation de certains véhicules
notamment il est il est question
d'augmenter le nombre de passes 24
heures possible pour un véhicule il est
question de 24 passes en une année donc
on augmente les dérogations et puis de
l'exécutive en métropole et également
annoncé que les services de l'État ne
seraient pas prêts pour les contrôles de
cette réglementation avant la mi-2024 il
faut des portiques et qui permettent de
scanner les plaques et donc de faire un
dispositif de contrôle automatique et ça
ne sera pas prêt à en 2024 et Olivier
vous avez des questions pour Olivier
Hainaut
oui tout à fait alors
ça a coupé alors on va essayer de vous
on va essayer de vous reprendre Olivier
Claudon je vais je vais poser votre
question du coup à olivierno la question
de Olivier c'était faut-il aller au-delà
de la loi climat et interdire le diesel
dans les villes oh non mais faut arrêter
moi les aides et feux voyez faire croire
aux gens qu'on va résoudre le problème
de de des gaz à effet de serre et du
réchauffement climatique
en sanctionnant les gens qui n'ont pas
les moyens d'avoir une voiture
électrique franchement ça suffit moi ça
me ça me met en colère cette histoire et
pendant ce temps-là on n'a rien fait sur
une question essentielle c'est c'est le
transport des marchandises il y a de
plus en plus de camions sur nos
autoroutes et de moins en moins
marchandise sur les trains alors
pourquoi est-ce que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile on bouscule des intérêts
économiques lourd et important c'est
plus facile de taper sur la voiture du
des petites gens moi je trouve ça c'est
de l'écologie faire croire aux gens
qu'on va résoudre le problème de
l'environnement et du réchauffement de
la manette avec des six types décisions
ça me révolte pendant ce temps là on ne
fait rien et on ne bouscule pas les
grands intérêts économiques je trouve
que c'est incroyable que que les
écologistes se livrent à des petites
questions comme ça qui sont graves parce
que les gens vont se révolter contre
l'écologie ils vont pas adopter cette
mesure ils sont contre aussi la
radicalité vous voyez qu'on abîme les
œuvres d'art tout ça mais enfin si on
veut que les gens rejettent l'écologie
qu'on continue comme ça moi je me
baladais l'autre fois à Roubaix et ou
même à Saint-André et je vais souvent
voir dans les dans les gens dans les
zones ou dans les zones d'habitat ou les
gens n'ont pas beaucoup de moyens mais
il y en a pas qui ont la vignette un ou
deux alors on va empêcher c'est ces
personnes dehors on va se donner bonne
conscience écologique sur le dos des
plus pauvres et ben moi ça me révolte
franchement je trouve ça incroyable
qu'on s'occupe de mettre les
marchandises sur les trains et qui est
moins de camions sur les autoroutes et
ça va là on va faire progresser la
question de l'écologie
rapidement Olivier on vous a retrouvé il
nous reste 30 secondes
oui alors la question c'est que la loi
imative est-ce que les
centenaires est-ce que décide et
parlementaires alors il faut aller plus
vite sur les transports collectifs la
qualité des transports collectifs il
faut aller plus vite sur les vélos à
libre-service il faut aller plus vite
sur des mesures contraintes mais pas je
contrôle je sanctionne donc je suis moi
je ne suis je ne crois pas ce genre de
décision de des pouvoirs locaux et c'est
très clair merci Olivier Claudon pour le
problème technique mais votre question a
été posée vous écouterez avec attention
la réponse de Livier nous on regarde la
une du des Diana c'est le Racing Club de
Strasbourg qui a fait match nul contre
Lorient le Racing et vite le pire c'est
à la Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
Olivier Claudon et merci Oliviero
d'avoir été avec nous dans 20 minutes
dans le club des territoires on ira à
Toulon débarquer ce weekend les migrants
de l'Océane Viking de sénateurs se sont
rendus hier dans le centre où sont
accueillis les migrants les a suivis on
verra le reportage dans 20 minutes